all right what's going on guys this is
Rob we are back with Immortal Thor and
storm fights Thor this is dope and
that's just the tip of it now before we
get into that whole thing we do have to
talk about Beta Ray Bill because he
becomes important later on in this story
so one of the things that happens here
is that back on Asgard Loki returns
after his whole little bit of a training
session with Thor at the end of the last
video that we did again as always we'll
have a link at the end of the video for
the Thor playlist so you can get caught
up it's pretty short not going to be
super long but when he arrives back
there there's kind of a discussion right
bet Ray bill has been on Asgard for
quite some time and in fact when he left
he's been called back by Sith the reason
for this is because there's a three-way
conversation here when Loki came back to
Asgard at the request of Thor he started
bringing people together specifically
betay bill because Bill is part of a
plan and in fact even Loki says I told
Bill the honest truth surely you lady CF
right the new Heim doll if you want to
call her that right she's technically
the sister of Heimdall but she took his
role and she sees everything the same
way Heimdall did after Heimdall died and
he ask her surely you saw the
conversation between myself and Thor and
while she does play a little bit koi in
the sense that like I only see things
that you allow me to see y y yadada for
the most part it's basically true right
and so bet Ray Bill kind of talks about
his role here and one of the things he
says is like I have fought alongside
Asgard for eons right for quite some
time but recently I don't know if I
trust Thor anymore and I don't know if I
trust the asgardians anymore now for
those of you guys who don't know the
reason for this the really quick and
simple explanation here is that at the
beginning of Donnie Kate's run on Thor
he became a Herald of Galactus and that
he was going to lead Galactus around to
these particular worlds in order to
allow Galactus to destroy them consume
their energy and then fight this
multiversal being called the black
winter because it would lead to the
deaths of Innocence bet Ray Bill tried
to stand in Thor's way and Thor beat the
crap out of him and so because of that
bet Ray Bill doesn't really trust Thor
in that capacity anymore but the
statement he makes is that he is a man
of honor and that in doing so he
basically says I fight alongside Asgard
so at the very least I will hear out
Thor and hear what he has to say now at
this point we transition over to
everything with storm now of course at
the end of the last video it was
literally Thor telling Loki I have to go
find storm Thor ends up traveling to
oraco because again storm during the
X-Men red comics of the moment is kind
of in the midst of this gigantic Genesis
War that's going on between the mutant
populations and so the result of this is
that the crows of Thor literally appear
and say you are summoned and just like
snatch her up right and just teleport
her directly to Thor now at this point
you have the two of them who are
seemingly on the moon and the result of
this is that Storm's like you better
return me back home man because like I
have some serious stuff going on right
but what ends up happening here is
Thor's Ravens appear to storm and
they're just like you've been summoned
and they basically whisk her away from
oraco teleporter to to the Moon where
Thor is waiting on her now the cool
thing here is that she says like I'm
busy I do not have time for this and the
reality is that's true right if you guys
are watching our coverage or you're
following our coverage of fall of X
right now in the X-Men red comic storm
is in the middle of the Genesis War this
war between like the mutant populations
on oraco formerly known as Mars and so
she's like I got stuff going on man like
literally I'm trying to keep my people
alive in the midst of this giant War I
don't have time for Dilly dallying right
and so at that point Thor simply says
well then I apologize for the abruptness
of the summons ofuro and she's like
apology accepted if you return me to
oraco now now here's a cool thing right
Al Ying is writing both X-Men red and
he's writing this and what you're about
to see here is what happens when you
have a writer that's writing two
different comic books and basically has
them cross over it's phenomenal because
as most of you guys know who are either
reading X-Men red or watching our videos
on X-Men red storm is dope in Marvel
Comics right now and she's more powerful
than she's ever been and so the thing
about this is she literally just like
snaps her fingers and lightning just
starts coming down hitting Thor because
like he's not going to let her go and so
the whole time this is happening he's
not necessarily just kind of like
smiling and laughing or anything like
that but it's a kind of source of
entertainment to a degree and so he just
basically tells like the lightning stop
hitting me right stop striking me and it
does it ends like it literally stops the
funny thing here is when auror is just
like why he's like I'm not talking to
you I'm talking to the lightning he's
like the lightning answers to me as much
as it answers to you right I command the
lightning and that's kind of been a big
question a lot of people have right like
if storm commands the lightning and Thor
commands the lightning who wins on that
little scuffle because we know that by
brute strength alone Thor would
absolutely dominate storm right in like
a physical hand-to-hand confrontation
but this is one of the things that aling
does that I absolutely love what what
she says is I trust this lightning to
convey the seriousness of my message and
though I enjoy the play of the lightning
there are more Universal forces
atmospheric pressure for example and
there are places where the atmospheric
pressure is high such as Jupiter she
literally changes the atmospheric
pressure around Thor in effect she
increases how much air is pushing down
on him it's similar to the effect of
somebody like graviton right increasing
the gravity around a person but in this
instance she can isolate it and increase
it around Thor but it's more than simply
just like pulling him down to the ground
it's just like increasing the density of
the air around him right his muscles are
screaming his bones are popping I mean
it's just it's absolutely crazy if you
were to do this to like a normal person
it would be as if this person were
suddenly teleported to Jupiter and
assuming they somehow had a way to
breathe in Jupiter's atmosphere they
would be crushed by the pressure right
down to a pulp right it'd be like going
to the very you know to the lowest point
it wouldd be like descending down to
like the bottom of the ocean right where
the pressure is just astronomically high
but Thor is able to withstand all of
this right and storm literally says you
command the storm Thor I command the
weather and not as a king on a throne
but I command it as an equal and this
right there just kind of like solidifies
who would win in a fight between the two
right like with Thor it's brute strength
lightning and that's more or less it he
does kind of command the weather to a
degree but not on the same level that
storm does and Storm's ability to
increase the pressure around him all
that kind of stuff she'd easily be able
to take on Thor I don't know if she'd be
able to destroy him or kill him but she
would certainly hold the upper hand for
quite a bit of time so I want to know
from you guys who do you think would
actually win in this now where this is
kind of like the end of the fight
between the two do not let that deceive
you because this story gets crazy so
what ends up happening here is he says
who's stronger right and she's like what
are you talking about and he says the
question those like us are always asked
who is stronger can I arm wrestle the
Hulk run a race with Quicksilver
challenge Willie Lumpkin in an ear
wiggling
contest right and so he literally takes
his hammer and throws it at her right
and then in turn storm catches it now
the funny thing about this is this would
be one of those things where we could
kind of dismiss it and say yet another
person who's lifting the hammer of Thor
and she's going to beat him with him
nope that's not going to happen it's not
going to be a fight between Thor and
storm with storm having the hammer
there's a much bigger scheme at play
here because as he throws it to her it
simply says whosoever holds the hammer
if they be worthy shall possess the
power of Thor and so literally once she
catches it he says and not a moment too
soon look up and tanos is back now for
those of you guys who aren't following
the Thor Mythos right now tanos is being
introduced to us as an elder god right
this is a guy who basically existed on
Earth in its earliest days guys like
kathon right they're just beings who
have been around since the early days of
existence and where most of them were
either destroyed defeated or took off to
other dimensions this is one of those
instances where this guy represents one
of these Elder gods and that's where
Storm is absolutely like totally
flabbergasted she was like you summoned
me to fight that thing she's like you're
right it was
urgent right and one of the things he
tells her is that when she says if you
don't have your Hammer you cannot be
Thor his response is no I have my own
power now because remember in his
training session with Loki Loki kind of
I wouldn't go as far as to say unlocked
a latent ability within Thor but Loki
taught Thor to think outside the box to
be more than just a God that has a
hammer and just uses it to hit stuff so
Thor is thinking on a much higher level
than he traditionally would and so where
you do have like this whole attack going
on between tanos and Thor and storm and
so on and so forth that Loki emerges out
of nowhere right and this is what Thor
counted on Thor counted on Loki
appearing here and in turn he tells
storm throw the hammer at Loki and so
when she does like Loki is just like
nope I'm not catching that thing right
like that's a hero's task If Ever I saw
one and fortunately I have one right
here he opens the portal Bay Bill
emerges and Bay Bill catches the hammer
right so it's just like you can kind of
see what's going on here right it's
being passed around the hammer is being
passed around to different people when
betay Bill finally gets the hammer back
he goes to the classic bet Ray Bill look
that we've all missed for so long right
I miss seeing bet Ray Bill in this whole
outfit right and so he officially
becomes The Returned Warrior of Asgard
and so that's when storm chimes in and
she says whenever you throw the hammer
to somebody and the person who had it
loses possession of it how long do the
Thor Powers last and his response is 60
seconds and we're all going to need that
60 seconds and so in turn the hammer is
held by baday Bill is handed to Loki
Loki grabs the hammer he becomes Thor
like storm touches the hammer again
becomes Thor and then the Hammer's
thrown to Jane Foster who arrives as
valkyri and she becomes Thor and so you
get like this just ridiculously dope
moment where this was the plan of Thor
like the plan of Thor was to throw the
hammer at storm to see if she was worthy
and if she was she would get his powers
then give the hammer to be R Bill who we
already knew was worthy so he would get
the Thor powers back give it to Loki to
see whether or not he can be worthy
which he is so now Loki this really
establishes he is a tried and true good
guy seemingly that's the case I don't
know if I really believe that the
inscription says whosoever holds this
Hammer if he be a good guy shall possess
the power of Thor it's not what it says
but Loki is worthy to lift the hammer
Jane Foster's back as Thor and Thor
literally tells this guy right like
behold tanos you could not defeat Thor
when he stood alone and now you face a
Thor core the Thor core Thor created an
army of himself with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you need to get caught up on the Thor
Comics make sure you guys click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace